hey let me tell you this these day
traders
are out of control okay
uh because they keep promising bigger
and bigger numbers and i wonder
has common sense checked in with any of
these guys
i mean it used to be that you would say
i made
like 600 bucks on a yellow call
now we're talking about turning 20k
accounts 30k accounts
into millions of dollars and some of you
guys believe it
all right team i'll check this out last
week's results
1.8 million guys how much are you now
currently uh as we're doing this
interview uh this week i passed 6.7
million
in profits right from 1500 of your own
money and so
you believe these people when they
they're just nobodies
and they claim to have made millions of
dollars with the stock market
and i don't know where the reality
checks need to start coming in
but these advertisements are getting
ridiculous and they must be getting
ridiculous because they work
on some people right like people do
believe this stuff and it's
unbelievable and guess what guys i've
officially turned
50 000 into one
million dollars in just two months this
is
noir trades page let's look at this
we're out of control this has gone too
far 18 year old turns 20k
into two million dollars in six months
of course he does
right and the tooth fairy helped him are
we insane have we lost
all common sense but if you go to his
instagram we see who this guy's about oh
sorry that's
our next guy that's trillionaire club um
this sorry this is our guy here we go oh
look at this guy look at the chat that
he rented for the photo shoot
i'm giving away 1 000
sorry to stop there dude you're trying
to flex on people
saying you made two million dollars in
six months and your giveaway is one
thousand dollars
buddy you need to if you're gonna
convince us that you're rich you're
gonna have to try a little bit harder
than that dude i think he
i think he overspent on the budget dude
look at that necklace
look at this car look at the jet he
overspent he's probably in debt
credit card debt from paying for this
little mini commercial on
on his instagram he couldn't afford the
giveaway dude my name is nora trades and
i'm known for turning twenty thousand
dollars into a little over two million
by the way i love when they do that i'm
known for insert what they wanna be
known for
like dude you're not known for that
nobody knows you for that you're trying
to get yourself known for that by saying
you're that hey guys what's up
coffeezilla here known for my sick cars
over here i
i don't even talk about them ever but
i'm just known for my
awesome cars they just sit there you
know no big deal guys you also may know
me for my gigantic
bank account just something i'm known
for i'm picking
10 lucky winners and i'm giving each one
a hundred dollars just because all the
support i've been receiving
you guys have been helping me out i'm a
millionaire so just for you guys just
because you're supporting me
100 it's time for me to give back
all you need to do is like this video
share this on your story
and tag three people in the comments
section it's a lot honestly for a
hundred dollars liking
tagging three people and sharing this on
your story that's a lot
but none of this is why we're talking
about noir trades today
because this guy has a moment on youtube
it's sort of one of those
youtube history moments uh like the boom
goes the dynamite kid
and boom goes the dynamite it's just
like this amazing piece of
internet that i don't think anyone's
caught onto yet i don't think anyone's
noticed
that this has happened except for me and
now you guys because
this guy ran a little commercial okay he
ran a little commercial on
loft's youtube channel if you guys know
this guy he does a bunch of chatting
with millionaire uh pieces he's pretty
pretty interesting guy but what happened
with noir trades is he actually had to
he doesn't have a big enough following
for loft to actually bring him on the
channel just normally um so the guy has
him pay
4 thousand dollars to get on his show he
goes i'll probably have noir trades on
again i'm all aware you guys think he's
a scam but she might be but he's paying
me 4k
this time so i can't refuse he's had
them all once before and which
he paid 3k that time so this kid is
paying to be on the guy's shop okay
that's an important part of this to
understand how hilarious this moment is
because he comes on the show so this is
a basically a commercial and bear in
mind this kid can barely afford a
thousand dollar giveaway so this is a
big buck
giveaway here he comes on this guy's
show and rather than getting a
commercial
he gets roasted the entire time this guy
makes money off people
not off stocks
we just went over that
well i actually just posted what's your
response to that
i mean people so look
i mean uh well yeah you see
andrew uh i mean people so
look i didn't think we'd be going over
this i paid you 4k
to be on your show i thought you'd help
me out i mean to be fair
under the fold there is he is shouting
the guy out he gives the registration he
is doing a commercial for him but
he brings up some hilarious stuff and
some of it rings really close to home
but look at how this sociopath answers
one of these questions because one of
them
is actually about one of his well-known
frauds this guy is a
known fraudster who stole signal
information from another guru he can't
even come up with his own guru crowds
ruthless um
just so everyone knows this guy is just
copying people from other
chats he's not legitimate watch out do
you reason there it is
guys did you see that look at this
response look at this response this is
something he has been
caught doing he's been caught stealing
from
other gurus and trying to sell it off as
his own now
[Music]
he wasn't even stealing that well and
we'll get into that in a second but look
at how he reacts to this
is that true yes i mean did you see
anything on my screen here
just had my discord open had my tos
okay now with that response of mine look
he goes he goes
is that true you stealing from people uh
well uh did you see me stealing from
anybody at this particular second
hey that's not what he asked but with
all this in mind with this
let's add some context to this because
noir trades
was caught definitively stealing from
another
youtuber uh and another guru called
stock
hunter trading now this guy i am not
at all endorsing him literally just take
one look at his twitter page to realize
what kind of quality information this
guy's giving out i'm sorry stockhonder
now how did he get caught well noir
trades
join this guy's uh discord chat remember
he's supposedly his origin story
it's like a superhero his origin story
was that he made millions of dollars in
the stock market when he was 18 years
old
so a year after this he's caught in this
guy's discord group
okay this is his email up here i'll blur
it out
um he's caught paying for this guy's
discord signals group and the guy starts
noticing
that he's on his own discord signals
group so this is where you pay for
someone's stock tips
idiotic uh this other guy's discord
stock group they were the same they're
giving out the same advice and noir
trades was giving it out like five
minutes after so the guy started
realizing oh he's
stealing my stock tips and just giving
it to his subscribers as if he thought
of it
so what he did is this he started
uploading to his chat room this is his
side right here and this is noir trades
over
on the right he started uploading his
with a watermark
okay i don't know if you guys can see
that down there there's a little
watermark he'll zoom in in a second and
the question is would noir trades copy
it with the watermarked image let's
check it out
i started my notes at 6 40 6
am nor trades came in at 6 52
am and copied me word for word
here is my company logo stockholder
trading
llc this is a watermark and he is
copying it
you literally can't get more busted than
this
and then imagine the fact that he's he
doesn't have the decency
to run away and stop being a guru and
just realize hey
obviously i was faking it guys haha got
a few of you you know you guys paid me
200 bucks a month for my discord signals
group and i got like 200 000
a month total i ripped you guys off but
haha i was just a prank bro
he doesn't even have the decency the
shame to do that
instead what he does is he goes on loft
he tries to run a commercial
thinking that no one's going to catch
him this guy's just copying people from
other
chats he's not legitimate watch out do
your research
dude i will pay for that to forever be
enshrined
that if i ever create a twitch chat or i
don't know if i can do this for like
youtube emotes
i want that to be one of them
dude just the realization i paid this
guy
four thousand dollars and he's bringing
up my
biggest most embarrassing moment of my
entire career
one that delegitimizes me forever by the
way if you ever
follow this guy's discord group while
knowing this you're an idiot
because clearly he doesn't know what
he's doing trading stocks
but not only was he stealing from this
guy he also was
asking for help so this is these are
things he posted to the guy's discord
group while he was still a part of it he
got kicked out
look at this okay so no swing would you
swing anything he's talking about swing
trading
shopify 290 calls for a swing he's
asking questions because he doesn't know
what he's doing
he doesn't know how to trade so he's
asking
for help from this guy who then he kind
of steals his whole thing
and again this is not like stealing from
warren buffett here
remember who we're dealing with here
guys this is so embarrassing
if this happened to me i would never
show my face again on the internet but
this kid doesn't care
he just keeps going and going and going
it's chats he's not legitimate watch out
do your research
anyway i just thought you guys would
really enjoy that let me know what you
guys think
this is just non-stop where do we draw
the line i think
anyone under 30 we should all not listen
to including myself dude
if we can all take this advice
collectively i'm happy for you guys not
to listen to my advice in fact i don't
really give advice
much i mean really i just tell you guys
who not to listen to
which is not hard to do because there's
so many idiots out there but i'm not
trying to tell you how to live your life
because frankly
i don't know listen jesus waited till he
was 30 to start
preaching if that's good enough for
jesus it's good enough for me i'm going
to wait till i'm 30
before i start spitting out my guru at
time while i'm 30
when i'm 30 i'm just going to create a
course and i'm going to tell you how to
live your life
but until then you shouldn't listen to
me and you shouldn't listen to all these
idiots
18 years old millionaire no
no dude are you kidding it's got to stop
at some point you gotta have some life
experience it's the caleb maddox thing
all over again dude
the kid is 17 trying to coach everybody
else
it's like dude you haven't earned that
right to be a coach you haven't done
anything
and so that's what i'm super passionate
about at some point we got to draw the
line i know that's going to get a lot of
people they're going to
say hey no i'm a 20 year old i'm a coach
but
i'm going to say no dude and if you
doubt me if you think i'm wrong
come on the show please it's been a
while since we've done a debate i'd love
to talk about this do you think
that 20 year olds should be coaches or
math they should be running masterminds
do you think uh
they should be teaching all the rest of
us let me know in the comment section
below i know that's a little sensational
and as always
don't forget to smash like and subscribe
thank you
[Music]
comes along